اخر المواقف الامريكيه من هذه الحرب
الاستخباراتيه الالكترونيه الامريكيه
الصينيه جاءت واضحه من البيت الابيض
مكافحه التجسس الصيني اولويه لدى الرئيس
بايدن يؤكد البيت الابيض
كما قلنا مرارا لدينا بالفعل مخاوف بشان
برامج هذه التطبيقات وناخذ مساله الامن
القومي على محمل الجد ذلك هو موقف الرئيس
بايدن بشان امن الامريكيين ومعلوماتهم
الخاصه
اجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه على تنوعها
مدير الشركات ناهيك بالمشرعين في الكونجرس
كلهم قلقون من التحركات الالكترونيه
الصينيه وحسب جوجل تضاعف الصين الان
جهودها واساليبها لاستهداف مواقع الشركات
الامريكيه بهدف التجسس سرا وجمع طائفه
واسعه من المعلومات دون علم الجهات
المستهدفه
انها هجمات من نوع جديد لم نعلم بها من
قبل يتعلق الامر ببرنامج خبيث يستهدف
الانظمه الالكترونيه التي تحمل الانظمه
اذا حدث هذا فسيتم الاستحواذ على معطيات
عدد من الشركات التي ربما لا علم لها اصلا
بانه تم استهدافها
بلغت المخاوف الامريكيه مداها بالتركيز
حاليا على منع تطبيق تيك توك الصيني وتسع
اداره بايدن في الوقت الراهن الى تخلي
المالك الصيني عن التطبيق وبيعه فيما يبدو
حلا وسطا والا فسيواجه تيك توك منعا كليا
في الولايات المتحده كما فعلت بريطانيا
لحمايه معلوماتها ومعطيات مواطنيها
تبرر الكونجرس اي قرار بعد بشان اساليب
الاختراق الصيني تلك ولكنها مساله وقت
فحسب على ما يبدو قبل ان يواجه المشرعون
الامريكيون الهجمات الصينيه الالكترونيه
بقوه التشريعات والاجراءات القانونيه نصح
حسين الجزيره واشنطن